hey what's going on this is jake
gyllenhaal
i'm yahya abdulmatine
and we are here with buzzfeed to figure
out if we can pull off a heist let's get
into it a haste a heast
why are you committing this heist to
help your family to help your best
friend to pay off your debts to have
more money
to buy a new car i don't know nothing
about no heist
i don't know nothing about no heist
that's me
but i also like to help your family
would be a nice it's like nice but you
know
all right now for the second most
important thing pick a getaway car
an ambulance
a school bus a mini cooper an armored
truck a race car
not a car a helicopter i know what i'm
gonna go with why wouldn't anyone pick
an armored truck to oh what because you
hide in plain sight that's a good one
don't steal that one mini cooper all
right race car yeah who are you stealing
from a bank
a jewelry store a casino
an enemy who's wronged you again i know
nothing about noah
there's a former employer on here too
the thing is is if you start with i i
don't know nothing about no heist you
just i think you kind of have to kind of
be yeah yeah because the system well i
mean maybe did i write this quiz because
i think again i don't know nothing about
no heist which iconic heist movie are
you watching for inspiration the italian
job ocean's eleven widows
inception set it off national treasure
where is uh their presidents dead
presidents yeah yeah
inception because
some of that trickery
could come in handy um ocean's eleven
okay pick a unique set of skills to help
pull off the perfect heist
computer hacking picking locks cracking
safes forgery these hands
driving charming finesse okay four green
pokery
what are you doing i'm i'm i'm i'm
you're not telling me you're not telling
the folks i don't know what you're going
to pick i picked charming for this hello
that was a little too aggressive
i just didn't think you should he
shouldn't keep that from us that's mine
that was my feeling all right okay
which song is the soundtrack to your
heist
sailing by christopher cross
california dreaming by the mamas and
papas money by pete floyd mo money mo
problems more money more problems by the
notorious yeah
oh feeling good feeling good by nina
simone how you like me now about the
heavy oh who picked these this
i'm going to say
like i was going to say the same thing
because like to like drive off yeah last
but not least
which fellow celebrity is joining your
heist squad simulator
megan the stallion tom holland michael b
jordan harry styles christian stewart i
might have to go with tom holland or
harry styles wow that's so interesting
because people trust white boys
i might want to make a white boy the
face of that crime okay well because we
may not even need an intricate getaway
we may be able to walk right on out the
front door if you pick the right white
board
michael b is pretty charming though okay
here we go let me get a pillow did
somebody have a pillow
i think we're gonna be here for a while
i'm gonna go with mike b wow look i'm
gonna see you see
i'm gonna go with mike b because he's
charming too the only reason why i'm not
gonna pick megan stallion because i
think you need agility with your hands
to open doors
like that and then nails will get into
so i'm gonna go with
tom holland which seems
you know
right
oh
did you get away with it got caught no
did you too many white boys
yeah i made it congrats it was touch and
go it was touching go there for a bit
but you made it out alive beautiful job
you really didn't make it because i
guess because i picked tom holland which
is
uh
i think it was forgery that did it
thanks buzzfeed this was fun this was a
lot of fun but i still don't know
nothing about no heist to catch
ambulance in theaters now peace
[Music]
you